Stick around to the end of the show, because today,
guess what day it is Rossi?
My favorite day.
Pop quiz.
Yes.
(alarm ringing)
That's right.
I do love pop quiz.
One lucky audience member is gonna be in the hot seat.
We'll ask you three questions about today's show
and if you get it right, you get a thousand dollars.
All right? So pay attention.
(audience applauds)
Welcome back.
It is time for another pop quiz.
(audience applauds)
(alarm ringing)
All right, where is audience member Latavia Young?
Hi. Hi, come.
By the way, I was staring at you earlier.
What is this outfit with these green boots
and hello to you.
All right, Latavia if you answer
all three questions correctly with today's show,
you're gonna win a thousand dollars.
Oh my God.
Are you ready?
I am ready.
Okay. All right.
All right.
The first question is, Judd Apatow joked
that he'd watch his daughter Maude Apatow's show "Euphoria"
after he's done watching this other show
that he is currently watching.
People reports that the Apatows are, you know
they like to kid around with each other.
And when Maude recently posted about the latest episode
of "Euphoria", here's what Judd replied.
Her dad said,
I'll watch it right after I finish "Yellowstone".
Oh God.
Okay. Okay, come on.
You said it like 50 times.
Oh my gosh.
"Yellowstone".
Yes!
(audience applauds)
Oh my gosh.
All right.
Here's your second question.
Insider says we should retire what wedding term?
We're talking about the wedding term
that some experts say we have to retire.
Anyone ever heard of the term bridezilla?
Oh my God.
Bridezilla. Yeah, I know that one.
(audience applauds)
I knew that one.
Yes. All right.
That means you have two questions right,
you just need the final question for a thousand dollars.
All right?
Okay. Drew?
Okay. Final question.
Name a craft Drew, Sophia Bush, and a friend of the show,
Leo Kelly and Sarah T made together.
And there you go.
You got a little themed piggy bank
or you could put tissues in it.
(audience applauds)
Right?
I like it.
Oh it's a piggy bank.
This is cute.
You guys made piggy banks.
Yes.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat music)
A thousand dollars for you.
(theme tune playing)